yeah i i always worry about their
physical safety that's just the nature
of fatherhood
that's barack obama opening up to cnn's
anderson cooper about his daughter's
political activism
and keeping them safe in the new
interview the former president of the
united states says that while his
daughters
22 year old malia and 19 year old sasha
are much wiser than he was at their age
he still worries about their physical
safety when they participate in protests
and rallies
like the one they attended last year in
support of the black lives matter
movement in the wake of george floyd's
murder
in terms of them having a good sense
of what's right and wrong and their
part and role to play and making the
country better i
i don't worry about that sasha malia who
were only 7 and 10 years old when the
obamas entered the white house are both
now in college
i've spent my children's entire life
raising them to be
independent confident young women
who are ready to build great lives for
themselves the data too says his
daughters and their peers have adopted
an attitude of let's
change it when faced with injustice they
have both a clear sense of
um that i see in this generation that
what you and i might have tolerated as
yeah that's sort of how things are their
attitude is why
let's change it and that's among not
just my daughters but it's among their
white friends
obama also shares they're more strategic
about changing the system
while he says they understand everyone
is human they won't tolerate certain
types of behavior
we don't expect everybody to be perfect
we don't expect everybody to be
politically correct all the time but we
are going to call out
institutions or individuals if they
are being cruel if they are you know
discriminating against people we do want
to raise awareness
despite having similar values as his
daughters
the 44th president revealed to james
corden on the late late show last year
that sasha and malia will not be
following in his political footsteps
you have to have a certain tolerance for
nonsense
and silliness and meanness frankly
to go into public service and
you know as a father i want to protect
my girls from that stuff
i think they are probably going to find
other ways to serve
rather than run for office themselves
but
you never know and if they decided to do
it obviously i would be
extraordinarily proud of them and the
two-term president hilariously shared
the ptsd moment
that he thinks will keep them out of the
office first of all
them as teenagers having secret service
guys
uh follow them when they were going out
on dates uh
i think probably uh has shut down
uh their interest in public service that
was
they still have ptsd from from uh guys
you know talking into their you know uh
wrist microphones and glasses
uh as as they're trying to go to a a
music concert but the proud dad couldn't
help but gush over his two daughters
they have turned into uh
just exceptional young one i i could not
be prouder of them
not just because you know they're smart
and
accomplished but they're they're just
kind people
and even though sasha and malia are now
older and off attending college
when e.t caught up with mrs obama
michelle
she reiterated the importance of
spending time together as a family
the most important thing about dinners
at our house is that we eat together
and that's an important time for us to
catch up we've had that ritual for our
entire lives
even in the white house i read about how
the president no matter how busy he was
he would stop his day
and make sure we could have dinner
together as a family